[Música]
gran parte de mi trabajo es presentar
datos y resultados información que
describa la realidad y la situación en
que vive en nuestro país y nuestras
regiones sin embargo muchas veces estas
cifras estos porcentajes no logran
narrar ni describir la verdadera
magnitud de la tragedia ante la que
estamos en nuestro país
es muy difícil mantener la esperanza y
alimentarla cuando somos testigos de
tanto dolor de tanto sufrimiento de
tanta violencia
hace unos días mientras presentaba en un
congreso en sinaloa una joven se levanta
y me dice yuki se llama
me dice a los jóvenes nos están matando
y tenemos mucho miedo qué podemos hacer
para que no nos maten
la pregunta por brutal y por sencilla a
la vez me toma por sorpresa y tratando
de ser muy honesto con yuki le dije que
por el momento no tenía una respuesta
para su pregunta
y es que la violencia nos afecta a todos
y nos preocupa a todos pero hay algunos
grupos de la población a quienes les
afecta más a quienes los vulnera más y
uno de esos grupos son los jóvenes
jóvenes como la mayoría la mayoría de
ustedes aquí hoy
por darles unos datos en méxico durante
2018 una de cada tres personas que
fueron asesinadas tenía entre 15 y 29
años de edad
la tasa de homicidios fue 42 por ciento
más alta entre jóvenes que entre el
resto de la población
del delito de trata 40 por ciento de las
víctimas fueron menores de edad
la tasa de desempleo entre personas de
20 a 24 años es del doble que del resto
de las personas y de estos jóvenes que
si tienen un trabajo el 60% trabajan en
la economía informal es decir con
salarios más bajos sin prestaciones de
ley y sin una garantía
mientras preparaba esta charla me
preguntaba cómo es ser joven hoy en este
contexto en este país
creo que tenemos que comenzar por
reconocer que como sociedad hemos hecho
un montón de promesas que no estamos
cumpliendo les hemos dicho a ustedes los
jóvenes que sí estudian tendrán un
futuro brillante que si se esfuerzan y
trabajan duro tendrán estabilidad
económica que si son honestos serán
reconocidos serán respetados por los
demás pero esto no sucede en la realidad
no es cierto hemos roto estas promesas
lo que quiero decir con esto es que les
hemos pintado un escenario en el que
todas las decisiones que ustedes toman
los ponen en riesgo y no estamos
satisfaciendo sus necesidades lo que
quiero decir es que ser joven
actualmente es peligroso y es muy
difícil
pero eso ustedes ya lo saben por
supuesto y podríamos pasar aquí mucho
tiempo revisando datos y cifras que
mostrarían como la realidad que ustedes
se enfrentan hoy es mucho más adversa
que la que enfrentamos otras
generaciones antes
sin embargo y a pesar de todo esto lo
que ustedes reciben constantemente de
nosotros los más viejos es una serie de
reproches es el mensaje de que ustedes
como generación no están a la altura les
estamos diciendo que son una generación
chafa que no se esfuerzan que no quieren
trabajar que son difíciles de motivar
que no se comprometen y una serie de
reproches como que a nosotros nos
educaron mejor que en nuestra época así
que había valores no como ahora y un
larguísimo etcétera
bueno como miembro de estas generaciones
más viejas quiero decirles hoy aquí que
todo esto es mentira no es cierto
hay muchas cosas evidentemente hay
muchas cosas que tienen que cambiar
porque están mal pero no son ustedes
son la cantidad y la complejidad de los
problemas que les hemos heredado
es todo lo que no hemos sido capaces de
cambiar durante décadas y que hoy se
presenta ante ustedes como un panorama
oscuro como un futuro incierto
quiero ser más claro ustedes no son los
culpables de este mundo y de este país
que les estamos entregando
a nosotros nos lo entregaron mejor a
nosotros nos dejaron un mejor país que
éste
bueno quiero decirles también que
ustedes no son los culpables de esta
realidad ustedes no han tomado hasta hoy
ninguna de las decisiones que nos
trajeron a este desastre
ustedes por ejemplo no son los culpables
de los gobiernos ineficientes torpes y
deshonestos que padecemos ustedes no son
los culpables del cáncer de la
corrupción que nos está literalmente
matando ustedes no son los culpables
del daño ecológico del cambio climático
que nos está condenado a desaparecer
como humanidad ustedes no son los
culpables del modelo económico salvaje e
inhumano al que todos los días rendimos
culto ninguna de estas cosas las crearon
ustedes
pero tengo que decirles también que si
serán ustedes si son ustedes los
responsables de corregir esto
y aquí esto es lo primero que quiero
pedirles quiero pedirles que asumamos
esta responsabilidad cuanto antes
tan trágica y tan terrible como parezca
la realidad tenemos que saber que no
tenemos otra realidad
así que nos conviene usar nuestra
indignación nos conviene usar nuestra
frustración como un motor de cambio
transformemos la realidad en lugar de
huir de ella sé que suena obvio pero
solemos evadir la realidad
solemos huir de la violencia nos
encerramos nos aislamos ignoramos el
sufrimiento a nuestro alrededor
levantamos muros más altos nos cambiamos
de ciudad y cuando llegamos a la otra
ciudad
y tiene problemas buscamos otra ciudad y
con la otra ciudad cuando le echamos a
perder nos volvemos a preguntar ahora a
dónde podemos ir el problema es que las
ciudades no son desechables
el asunto es que estamos interconectados
y no es posible que vivamos en paz
mientras otros están sufriendo por mucho
tiempo hemos creído que era posible que
yo me sintiera seguro mientras mi vecino
tenía miedo por mucho tiempo creímos que
mi bienestar era independiente y no
tenía nada que ver con el bienestar de
los otros pero hoy sabemos que no nos
hemos dado cuenta de que por más que
huyamos de la violencia por más que nos
aislemos ésta siempre termina por
perseguirnos por encontrarnos de una o
de otra manera tarde o temprano
lo que quiero decirles con esto
es que nosotros no somos ajenos a esta
realidad que estamos tratando de
transformar nosotros somos parte de esta
realidad no estamos aislados de ella y
que si queremos comenzar a transformarla
necesitamos empezar a transformarnos
nosotros necesito cambiar yo primero yo
sé que esto está muy trillado ya lo sé
se ha dicho mucho y sé que esto el
cambio de uno no es la solución a todos
los problemas evidentemente lo reconozco
pero sí estoy convencido de que todas
las soluciones posibles comienzan por
ahí
regresando a la pregunta de yuki en
sinaloa
pues le dije que honestamente no tenía
respuesta pero pues tal vez tratando de
no ser un completo inútil para ella le
propuse en cambio algunas cosas que
podrían reducir la violencia en su
entorno le propuse tres cosas muy
concretas primero desactivar la
violencia que nosotros cometemos hacia
los demás el machismo la misoginia la
homofobia el racismo la discriminación
todas esas y muchas más son formas de
violencia que todos cometemos en mayor o
en menor medida todos los días y que por
ser cotidianas se han vuelto
imperceptibles y se han vuelto incluso
normales segundo no toleremos la
violencia hacia nosotros hay que
defendernos hay que levantar la voz hay
que poner límites buscar aliados pedir
ayuda pero no permitamos que nos
violenten y tercero solidaricémonos con
los demás hay mucha gente que sufre en
nuestro entorno hay que tocarlos hay que
defenderlos hay que ayudarlos hay que
acompañarlos
si queremos realmente transformar
nuestro entorno por ahí podemos comenzar
con los que no se pueden defender con
los que más sufren
algo que necesitamos saber es que no
estamos condenados a vivir con miedo
ni la corrupción ni la violencia son
nuestro destino
sino apenas una etapa muy oscura que ya
ha durado mucho y que eventualmente
pasará
necesitamos saber que no siempre hemos
vivido así
yo tengo 38 años y mi generación es
quizás la última generación que recuerda
haber jugado en la calle haber ocupado
los espacios públicos sin miedo la vida
en comunidad
el problema es que muchos de ustedes no
recuerdan esto porque nunca lo han
vivido entonces cuando hablamos de paz
no saben a qué paz nos referimos
y para crear algo es necesario primero
imaginarlo y para crear algo juntos es
necesario imaginarlo colectivamente por
eso hoy los invito a que soñemos juntos
con una mejor ciudad con un mejor país
con una mejor realidad
no no es suficiente saber qué es lo que
aborrecemos necesitamos también saber a
qué aspiramos necesitamos saber hacia
dónde vamos por eso es fundamental que
seamos capaces de soñar juntos incluso
en medio de las balas
y para lograrlo nos necesitamos a
ustedes los jóvenes necesitamos su
creatividad su imaginación su audacia ya
les digo nosotros no sabemos cómo
resolver esto que hemos descompuesto si
les decimos que hacer por favor no nos
hagan caso
bueno acepte esta charla si es en mi
caso por favor pero todo lo demás no nos
hagan caso a nosotros no sabemos mire
les pongo un ejemplo he estado en muchas
reuniones donde se juntan expertos para
discutir sobre violencia y hablar sobre
lo que los jóvenes necesitan como los
protegemos cómo hacemos estrategias para
cuidarlos para que tomen mejores
decisiones si entre comillas saben
quiénes son los únicos que nunca están
presentes en estas reuniones
y ustedes los jóvenes nunca están por
favor no nos permitan tomar decisiones
sobre ustedes sin ustedes levanten la
voz critiquen exijan estar presentes se
exijan ser escuchados
es muy importante que ustedes sepan que
no son los culpables de esta realidad
que les estamos entregando
sin embargo tienen que saber también que
el único camino posible es la
colaboración colaboración intersectorial
colaboración interdisciplinaria
colaboración intergeneracional
necesitamos para construir un mejor
futuro sentarnos dialogar ponernos de
acuerdo y trabajar juntos no hay más
nadie puede solo
así que por favor organícense
asuman liderazgos busquen aliados tejan
redes
ofrezcan y pidan ayuda
porque el reto que estamos enfrentando
es enorme
les decía al principio que es muy
difícil mantener la esperanza en este
contexto y sin embargo nuestra esperanza
es que ustedes sean más inteligentes que
nosotros que ustedes sean más éticos más
sensibles más honestos nuestra esperanza
es que ustedes sean mejores seres
humanos de lo que nosotros hemos sido
así que por favor cuenten conmigo y
muchos otros que estamos dispuestos a
colaborar con ustedes porque la
construcción de la paz es un camino
largo y muy difícil pero es un camino
que se recorre mucho mejor acompañado
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]